i need ideas i think i think i think
it's just creative block as usual
[Music]
hello hello
happy
sunday
so
we are actually going up to the bay area
this week just sunday to like saturday
or something like that we've got a
wedding to go to i'm gonna go see
scott's parents because we haven't seen
them since we moved so we're driving up
with the dogs
they're hanging out we just stopped for
lunch i usually make bento for us for
the road
because i don't want to always eat
mcdonald's because it makes my stomach
hurt and so here's what we got leftover
heinen's chicken with broccoli and rice
i also brought a lot of snacks too this
is this is scott's
portion but i just feel a lot better if
i can just eat home-cooked food on the
road because
it's just a lot nicer i think
all right you guys
what do you think ellie this is your
very first road trip up to the bay are
you
you're confused about where we're going
and why we're so far from home huh
corner
hi boyd
[Music]
thank
you right
we're back down where we live we're
going to our favorite coffee spot
because we missed it so dearly and it
was so good when we used to come every
day before work
and now that we're here
we're gonna get coffee i got this wallet
[Music]
[Applause]
hi good job
oh man that's delicious
that's so good how's your how's your
coffee spot it's so good it's so good
what'd you get i got i just got the
spice chai because i didn't need that
much
but hey
viewers if you're ever in mountain view
california definitely check out one
ounce coffee because it's
top notch
coffee i miss it a lot
[Music]
oh what a good boy
so
cute
[Music]
happy saturday
we are going to la today to meet up with
your friends and having a little food
adventure something we've been wanting
to do for a long time and we definitely
don't take advantage of the fact that we
live so close to la because san diego is
like
an hour or two deadly depending on where
you're going there
so we're gonna eat a bunch we've also
brought the dogs with us too
uh because
why not they're not gonna come eat with
us but they're just coming along for the
ride so super excited for today
let's go
[Music]
watch for the noodle pool
dude
that is so good
i've never had something like this
[Music]
we are now on our way to go meet a
friend of ours that a lot of you
probably also know don't they scott
maybe probably if you were there with me
on twitch streams and stuff you
definitely know who she is we are now
going to
is it a friend
that you
make sure to like and subscribe
[Music]
scott yes does your parents ever tell
you to not go empty-handed to a friend's
house
no no and yes and yes explain
some people some people
thought you should give gifts to and
other people not yes i see well
my parents always told me to bring
stuff to whoever's house we're going to
regardless and i always thought it was
so uncool
to do that
[Music]
and now i'm doing it
it's like
i don't know i just think it's a kind
thing to do to bring a gift
to whoever's house you're going to
unless of course you go to this person's
house all the time yeah sorry
sorry
but
i mean they bring stuff
they bring hot cheetos
great gift in my book i mean
we just don't bring stuff over us we
don't bring stuff over to their house
either unless we have something we want
to share with them oh yeah so
i don't know i just think it's a nice
thing we're giving them some pineapple
cakes but because tis the season and i
put in a nice box and made it look nice
because it's just nice to receive gifts
especially if their food food gifts are
the best gifts i think
did you think
but also gifting is like a whole thing
too because it's like you don't want to
get them anything too expensive or
anything too cheap but it's some i think
you can't go wrong with giving them
something that you enjoy okay
anyway
let's go see our friend then you
probably know it's chloe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello
oh you're so cute
he's so cute
[Music]
hello
all these new people
hi
where are you reading from
how do i know
[Music]
oh it's mayuko no way
no way no way mayuko really
no ah
absolutely not i cannot believe it
[Applause]
girl
imma cry imma cry
oh damn for sure
dude
[Music]
genuinely so cold right now
which
means it's time to bust out the hoodie
are you nice and cozy right here nope so
i want to take a moment to talk about
this thing that i got um i got this
right before our trip to the bay area of
like a month almost a month ago now and
this is the bellroy sling mini and i'm
sponsored by bill roy for this video so
thank you so much to bellroy i actually
got two of their products this is one
and then i also got the hide and seek
wallet for scott because his
old one was falling apart so i thought
it was a good chance to just kind of
replace it
and we've both been really happy with
these packs i got this color it's got
like a cute little yellow detail on it
also one of the things that i really
like about this one is that it comes
apart like this um this part is magnetic
and so it's really nice because i'll
wear it like this usually
but then when i get in the car i'm just
like oh shoot i have to take it off and
i
am so inflexible that sometimes when i
do like these kinds of motions and stuff
but like my back spasms or my arms
spasms but i like this because i can
just unclasp it and it just comes apart
and i can just put it on the seat next
to me i also let scott talk about how
he's liked his wallet here scott would
you say you like your new wallet this
one yeah yeah okay what do you like
about it it's been a while since i had a
like a full wallet
yeah
yeah what did you have before i had one
of those like just the card thing you
could barely even fit money in there so
you like put not that i have any money
in here i don't carry cash would you
recommend this for other people yeah do
you think other people would enjoy it as
much as you have yeah
it's a secret compartment
is that where you keep your secret
monies uh yeah
is that where you're hiding in cash that
i can't spend
bro has actually been around for a while
they're an australian company they were
founded in 2010 y'all probably know them
for their walls and they started doing a
lot more stuff like slings and backpacks
and stuff like that i was really pleased
to find out that they're also a
certified b corp which means that
they're doing business
for good to make good things for
the good of people and the earth which
is great but yeah they upcycle a lot of
materials and use as sustainable
um things as they can they've like
upcycled five million plastic water
bottles to turn into a recycled
polyester for their bags and
wallets and stuff like that so yeah
genuinely very happy with these so thank
you bellow for sending these over and
for sponsoring this video you can get 10
off of your purchase on bellroy by using
the link in the description box down
below um the promo only applies by
clicking that link you can't like just
go to bellroy.com or like look up
bellroy on google you have to use the
link in the description box down below
alright it is really cold but i still
have to do some work in the afternoon
and so i'm gonna get going i made some
tea i'm gonna have a cozy old time doing
some work so i'll see you later
hello happy monday from ellie and i
she's napping though oh it's been a week
since we did our little tiny la day trip
and uh last week
we just kind of
worked
fully and stuff but i just finished
recording an episode of movies corner
with someone that i had admired for so
long his name is mike lee i saw him do a
bunch of talks
for
like a lot of ios dev conferences that i
went to his talks genuinely like always
changed my life because they're not like
the typical tech talks i guess of just
like here's how you use this technology
your programming language better his
stuff is just like yo the earth is
burning what are we
my software engineers gonna do about it
and it always like is the type of talk
that like
i'm like man i wish there was more stuff
like this i got to interview him for
mugo's corner which is going to be both
a video episode and a podcast episode
but man i was so nervous because this is
the first time that i was like talking
to him synchronously one-on-one
and
i think i first
came to know of him in
2015 so like the first year that i did
ios development and now
i can talk to him on stuff like this and
it was so cool and my brain is whizzing
and i'm very hyped up on coffee and
stuff but it was really cool i'm working
on relaunching mooco's corner season one
was all live stream
like
stuff uh with a live audience season two
and maybe onwards from now on it's gonna
be
just a recording it'll be available for
free this time to
everyone who's subscribed to my youtube
channel and it'll also be available as a
podcast as well if you look at mooco's
corner so working on relaunching that so
that'll probably be out like end of
october-ish at least this episode
because i have a couple of other
episodes which were super super fun to
do i've been also working on uh
relaunching my newsletter as well which
i know i've been talking about that for
a long time but it just takes time to
put together when you're one of the
only people working on it so that's also
gonna come in october as well
but i am excited for those things it's
like the end of the year and
every time like last october was like
one of my busiest months because
i just had a lot of videos to do that
month and
that's no different for this year sort
of so i've been thinking a lot about
what kind of videos do i want to make
for the rest of the year and i have been
making a lot of career tip videos
because to me i'm always just like i've
always thought about making those videos
but i never did
and i was like i know that i can provide
value and insight and advice that's
really actionable to people in a way
that's hopefully engaging and easy to
understand so i made a bunch of those
videos to just stay on my channel
because i know that
they're helpful no matter where or who
you are sort of but i haven't wanted to
get more into just like
other kinds of content sort of
and i think it's one of those dilemmas
you know tech youtubers in general like
i think all of us face are just like
how do you break free from the tech
topic or how do you expand
your channel content to be more than
just about coding and it's difficult
when the coding stuff the very tech
oriented stuff do well on youtube
because then you're like oh people like
this so i should make more of this
but like
i don't know i think
maybe not all of us maybe most of us
definitely some of us at a certain point
we're like yeah but we have so many
other interests in life that we want to
make content about which is why i made
my own video the other day because i was
like i need to make something for myself
y'all like i just need to make
something for myself so
i did that and it was great and i
appreciate all of you who watched it so
i don't know
let me know what you want to see
i know i've asked that a bunch of times
and i don't always make the videos that
you suggest
but i take your ideas and i put them
through my own calculator like how do i
make it how i make how do i make it
interesting and engaging and valuable
and how can i make a video that i'm
proud of that i would watch that i would
seek out or that i would click on that's
a hard equation to put it through
sometimes so
i think i think i think
it's just creative block as usual i'm
gonna start posting short form content
as well which means i'm going to be on
tick tock so you can follow me on tick
tock
but
life of a content creator fam it's
literally just like
thinking about how all of these
different pieces fit together
and how do i package it in a way
that is interesting and engaging
insightful entertaining and
authentically me that's just a spill of
what's in my brain right now but it's
noon so i think i'm gonna make lunch i
don't know what i'm gonna make yet
but probably noodles it's usually
noodles okay
see you soon
[Music]
you